soylent is people it explores what's
possible when we start embedding humans
paid crowd workers into our interfaces
soylent is an add-in for microsoft word
that gets human help to support tasks
that word can't do well
shortening proofreading and open-ended
editing via macros
it does this by recruiting workers on
amazon's mechanical turk service to
solve hard ai problems for just a few
cents
each member of the crowd does a little
bit of work so it's like having tens or
hundreds of people help you write your
document one of soylent's features is
called shorten
shorten helps writers cut down their
text it's tough to trim a document to
meet a size limit it takes time and it's
hard to look objectively in your own
writing shorten ask mechanical turk
workers to find parts of the document
that can be cut down without changing
your meaning and then offer a few
rewrites its interface gives you direct
control over the length of the text drag
the slider to specify the length you
want for your paragraph and shorten
combines the edits to match we've
shortened text ranging from blogs
academic papers and rambling emails and
we got cuts down to about 85 percent of
the input each time we paid workers
about 1.50 per paragraph you can pay
less but you'll wait longer for workers
to pick up your tasks since they're less
lucrative we got it down to about 30
cents
crowdproof is a distributed human
proofreading service microsoft word
misses all sorts of obvious grammar
errors that humans can catch
crowdproof finds these errors explains
in plain english what the problem is and
offers anywhere from one to five
rewrites we've used crowd proof to clean
up texts like non-native english writing
bad wikipedia pages and paragraphs full
of errors that word can't find word
finds about thirty percent of the errors
in these texts crowdproof finds about
two-thirds of them and fixes about 90 of
the errors it finds
last is the human macro a natural
language crowd scripting interface
usually users would need to translate
their ideas into code which is tough
instead the human macro lets you
automate complex actions by describing
what you want naturally in words
launching the human macro opens a
request form where you can write what
you want like you would a craigslist
post
our goal here is to keep users from
launching buggy commands so we show a
live preview of what the request will
look like and let the user do a test run
on a single paragraph or sentence
our users have gotten the human macro to
transform a short story from past tense
to present tense to find creative
commons licensed images to describe a
paragraph and to flesh out citation
sketches into a real references section